欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们我们前面已经讲了关键词词根怎么样去确定
以及关键词的分类以及关键词的查找选择的一些方法
那么这节课我们来理解一个非常非常重要的概念
这个是直接决定着我们循环转化率高低的一个重要的因素
首先什么是真正的关键词和产品匹配呢
这个85%的运营甚至90%的运营都理解错误了
都没有真正的去理解词跟产品的匹配要素
词跟产品的匹配是根据买家的偏好和需求去把关键词和产品匹配的
也就是我们所说的关键词跟产品匹配是根据买家的偏好跟需求去进行匹配的
词品不是字面上的意思
我们很多人还停留在字面上的意思
比如说T恤手机
你觉得你的词是T恤
那么你匹配的产品是T恤
就是准确的
那这是非常离谱的一个理解的概念
比如说有些人推广手机这个词
那么他觉得他的产品就是手机
所以说他觉得匹配
这也是非常离谱的一个
持品匹配的一个概念
混淆
那么只有我们根据买家的偏好额
他的需求去进行
关键词跟产品真正的匹配
才能够真正的提高我们指动它的转化率
所以说我们在推广的时候
就起到非常非常重要的作用
那么字面意思就是刚才我讲的
大家都这样理解
所以说就会导致他推广
效果差
没结果
那么我们来看一下这个
买家
关键词跟产品
他们之间的关系是怎么样的
比如说买家A
他可以收关键词1
也可以收关键词2
也可以收关键词N
是不是
那么
关键词里面
这个关一种关键词
是不是很有可能匹配
多种类型的产品
比如说我这个买家
美国的买家
搜索关键词
搜索T恤
关键词
搜索T恤关键词
这个产品一可能是黑色的T恤
这个产品二可能是蓝色T恤
这个产品三可能是
黑色
加蓝款的T恤
这是黑色的
这是蓝款的T恤
是不是
T恤这个只能够匹配这么多这么多产品
买家A还可能搜索一个关键词
很有可能搜索
卫衣
这个词可能搜索其他的品类
比如说裤子之类的其他的衣服
所以说这个买家呢
他是根据不同的关键词去寻找对应的产品的
所以都是多对多的关系
一个关键词可能对应多种产品
一个产品也可能对应多个关键词
是吧
就是这样
所以说关键词只是
买家跟产品之间的一个桥梁
你要理解了这个之后
你就会知道你推广的时候
很有可能你推广
某个关键词匹配的
产品是1
但是实际客户需求的是
产品2跟产品3的这种类型
所以就会导致你
产品1
转化很低
当你把这个词
转成推广
产品2跟产品3的时候
很有可能你的
循环转化率就提升了
所以我们要从源头去判断
去分析客户的需求
再把
他们偏好的产品推广给他们
那么这样我们的
直通车的循环转化率才会更高
刚刚讲的其实就是这个模型
持品匹配的
中间这一部分
就是持品匹配这一部分
就是我们要做的话达成这一部分
板块就是持品匹配
那么这边的关键词非常多
产品也非常多
但是能够真正
实现
高转化跟
优质寻盘就是这么一点点
最后面
我们来举一个例子
当客户搜索某个关键词A的时候
关键词A可能匹配的产品是
B可能是C可能是D可能是E
也就是A这个产品可以匹配
在
B, C, D, E
这几个产品中都被使用在这几个产品当中
比如说当客户偏号A这个关键词搜索的时候
美国人
搜索A这个关键词
同时美国客户喜欢的产品是
B, C这个两个款产品的款式
也就是美国人偏号
B产品跟C产品这两种款式
那么我们直动车可能你推广的时候
把关键词A
A
刚好匹配
去推广BC
你的直动车
也是推广BC
那么这个时候
推广到了美国这个国家的时候才算是真正的关键词跟产品匹配
如果这个时候
美国人收A这个关键词
你推广的是
D和E这两款产品匹配的是A
给到美国人
推送到美给到美国人
是不是
这个时候美国人就不喜欢
D跟
E这个两个产品
是不是会导致你的转化率会低
所以说
这个时候我们
不要
只看字面上的关键词跟产品匹配
就一定有转化
这是对概念的
不解
我们必须
从买家的偏好关键词跟
产品的偏好款式去
满足他的需求去考虑
才能够真正的让
我们的
词
跟产品匹配上
才能够
获得
寻盘的高准化
对这个概念一定要理解透彻
然后多去思考
怎么样
知道
美国佬
喜欢这个款式
怎么样
知道
美国人
喜欢用这个词收
我们在
上一小节已经讲了
怎么样知道美国人偏好哪些关键词
然后我们又怎么样知道美国人
喜欢哪种款式
那么这个喜欢的款式呢
我们可能需要去测试
另外呢我们也可以去参考
当前
市场参谋里面的
一些美国偏好的款式
去选择相应的款
或者是去看
我们
同行
在美国
成交概率大的那些
款式
去进行跟这些词
匹配
那么我们才能够
让我们的
词跟品更加匹配, 循环转化率更高
所以我们一定要根据买家的偏好需求去把握关键词和产品匹配
一定要记住这个关系
然后再
按照这个逻辑去
运营
那么我们的效果一定会
这节课我们就先讲到这里